blad Smiths welcome to the forge if you
look down at your anvils you'll see a
5160 bar stock of Steel now today you
will not be forging blades in your
signature style instead you'll be
forging buoys your 3-hour Forge time
starts now so first thing I'm going to
do is try to weld a handle on it I hate
tongs is fairly thick so I'm going to
start thinning the steel
out
I hate tongs you really ought to shape
those tongs put the tongs in the Forge
get them hot form them right to the
steel my plan for the round is to try to
get my stock brok down and my blade
forged out as quickly as possible and
I'll just cut that leftover material for
the guard so next I break the stock down
I just cut it at an angle so that I
already have some of my point
formed so when I'm making a Bowie knife
with a DG guard that's cool I can do
that big old piece of Steel glad we got
big machines for
it so I hammer the handle out it gets 3
in wide pretty
quick now Tom can pull that dard out of
there stretch it out not overheat it he
could really set himself up
wonderfully I'm trying to remove some
Hammer marks that I have in my
blade Andrew's shape is beautiful but
it's lean buoy I would just like to see
him draw it out more
I got my stock broke down from my guard
already I made it out of the same buet
as the blade while I'm working on the
blade I get that
hot and try to go back and forth between
the
two I'm heating both sides evenly then I
bring the whole thing up to
temperature Andrew's in the oil thought
he was going around and around but he's
going back and forth I don't see any
warps in my blade yeah my blade looks
it's awesomely
straight I need to get this knife
hardened it's kind of like having
children you never feel like you're
ready but if you wait until you're ready
you never do
it like Tom just quenched his
blade it's not hard I could dig a trench
in it without F I'm starting to feel
like I'm doing something wrong and kind
of worries me a little bit so I have to
go back and do it again
if this doesn't Harden the knife then I
guess I'm just going
home W that was close
yeah all right let's
see well that's better I'm quenched my
blade is hard all I got to do is get it
into a shape that looks good and I'm
good to
go I test my Blade with a magnet when it
reaches crb critical temperature steel
becomes non-magnetic that's when it
traded a heat treat immediately into the
[Music]
quench it looks a little bent so I go to
my secret weapon a straightening jig
it's nothing more than a piece of angle
iron and a flat piece of bar stock I'm
going to clamp it in that straighten it
out let it sit there and cool down 5
four 3 2 one blade Smith shut down your
machines drop your tools your forging
time is
over gentlemen welcome to the strength
test our dreaded nail chop test the
strength and durability of your blades
I'm going to hammer your buoys three
times into these 12-in nails keep in
mind it's not what we do to these nails
that's what these nails are going to do
to your buoys you ready Tom well we'll
see if if I want to chop a nail I get a
chisel you don't use a knife for that it
only takes the tiniest amount of
anything to be wrong for it just to turn
catastrophic oh
jez oh Tom you lost your top guard there
most of
it yeah but your handle still on tight
your didn't come
apart and your blade held up nice
job Andrew are you ready not really
we're going to do it
anyway I'm feeling nauseous but as long
as I can hold up reasonbly well I think
I'll do this
fine
well
Andrew you got some chipping and
deformation right here chipped out a
little bit down here second and third
blows Le deformed out but overall it
held up well good job thank you Tim what
you thinking uh I just peed a
[Music]
little Andrew's Edge has Edge damage Tom
lost part of a guard so anything could
go wrong at this moment
[Music]
There is almost no damage to this Edge
Tim and the big thing is the alignment
the handle is also a bit off so when I'm
holding it it feels like that blade
pointing at you and it's actually
pointing off to the side but apparently
that heat treat is nailed and the edge
geometry is good too nice
job blad Smiths this is the sharpness
test to see how sharp the edge of your
blades are I will take your buoy and
last we ac cross e size of beef Tom
you're up first you ready I'm ready
let's do
[Music]
this well Tom the feel of your handle
you have these grooves over here so it's
easy to index the blade did most of the
work and you can see you have very deep
lacerations in there overall your blade
will cut thank you sir and do your next
you ready let's do it let's do
this all right Andrew it feels good when
you put your hand in it's got a good
weight to it it is sharp it lacerates
easy easily letting the weight of the
blade do all the work your blade will
cut thank you all right Tim it's your
turn all righty let's do
[Music]
this well Tim your handle bit on the
wider side but when you swing it the
weight of your buoy lacerates through
the beef easily your buoy will cut thank
you blade Smiths the judges have
completed their deliberation they've
made their final decision the blad Smith
leaving the forge
[Music]
is Tom your blade did not make the cut
Tom I really love the way you address
the issues that we talked about you
fixed your aaso creatively that was
great but that heating and quenching in
water made your handle and guard area
very brittle and you lost that top guard
so you suffered a significant blade
failure that's why we're letting you go
today yes sir Tom please surrender your
weapon I'm a sword maker I came here and
I made a knife and I think I made a good
knife Tom will get time in the sun when
Tom earns time in the sun it's okay I'll
take my glory when I earn
it